les Toulousains se sont réunis en masse
pour prendre le départ de la
mobilisation ce matin partout en France
même combat comme ici à Marseille
ou encore à Rennes dans les casseroles à
Saint-Dizier les manifestants adaptent
les traditions il est très important il
fera date donc il faut y être il sert à
dire que nous ne passerons pas à autre
chose tant que cette réforme ne sera pas
retirée il sert aussi à dire que nous
voulons enfin que nos aspirations soient
mises à l'ordre du jour c'est-à-dire des
augmentations de salaire l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes une
amélioration des conditions de travail
ou la prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux
concert de trompettes
et de casseroles pour se faire entendre
cette année ça pouvait pas mieux tomber
on vient de vivre une réforme des
retraites on avait vécu trois mois de
mouvement social qui est le plus
puissant de ces 40 dernières années une
forme de surdité de la part du
gouvernement sur la question des
retraites mais aussi sur la question du
travail qui est très lié à l'action des
retraites et donc on a décidé de faire
un premier mec et historique parce que
pardon toutes les organisations
syndicales sont présentes
[Musique]
pourquoi sans jour que nous ne lui
donnons pas
dans la conclusion serait le 14 juillet
et nous lui apprendrons à cette occasion
à bien comprendre toute la signification
d'insurrection contre l'arbitraire et
l'ancien régime que signifie aujourd'hui
et pour toujours et pour la terre
entière le 14 juillet et la Marseillaise
tous sont venus écouter les cadres du
parti Marine Le Pen et le président
Jordan Bardella lançait la nouvelle
campagne intitulée pour la paix sociale
mais alors pourquoi Le Havre ville ou
Marine Le Pen a terminé troisième au
premier tour de la présence ciel dans un
département où le RN n'a aucun député
beaucoup non plus l'impression de vivre
mais de survivre
de travailler en vain ne s'inquiéter
pour les siens pour l'avenir pour la fin
du mois pour demain ou même pour ce soir
je crois qu'on est parfaitement en
raccord ici au Havre pour tenir ce grand
rassemblement d'abord parce que le
rassemblement national c'est le premier
vote dans l'électorat du monde du
travail chez les ouvriers chez les
employés dans la France qui bossent
l'impression d'être plus chez nous
quand des quartiers entiers des villes
même deviennent des enclaves étrangères
aussi à ce que nous sommes et que
certains veulent importer chez nous des
interdits d'autres lieux ou parfois
d'autres temps on la sur ce choix n'a
donc rien à voir avec Édouard Philippe
mère de la ville et surtout possible
candidat à l'Elysée en 2027 même quand
Jordan Bardella assure que le RN est
chez lui au Havre et affiche les
ambitions de son parti pour les
prochaines municipales mais bien sûr a
répondu l'ancien Premier ministre et
enfin dans la
avec la retraite à 60 ans que nous
avions décidé et mis en place en 1981
pour laquelle nous nous sommes battus et
que nous récupérerons soyez-en certains
moi je pense absolument pas que ce
premier ministre sera en boucle et final
et qu'après on passera tous à autre
chose mais c'est ce qu'il veut dire
c'est que ça va être une mobilisation
inédite alors ils ont raison c'est une
grande fête populaire qui s'annonce une
immense démonstration de solidarité on a
des chiffres de mobilisation qui sont
historiques sur un 1er mai donc c'est
bien le signe sur la question sociale
pas sur la question politique comme on
l'avait eu en 2002 sur la question
sociale c'est le signe que la le
ressentiment et la colère ne baisse pas
l'invitation leur sera adressée dans les
jours qui viennent nous ne sommes ni un
jour ni à une heure cette semaine
on a reçu toujours aucun courrier ni
ordre du jour donc la première chose ça
serait de commencer par ça ensuite nous
avons une inter syndicale demain lors de
laquelle nous déciderons ensemble ce que
nous ferons un berger décidé oui ben
nous on va décider en inter syndicale
c'est pas moi qui fait l'agenda de la
première ministre et je serais très
heureux surtout que ces réunions
puissent se tenir et que nous puissions
avancer et ça pourrait être dès cette
semaine ça pourrait être dès cette
semaine début de semaine prochaine ça
dépendra des disponibilités de chacun et
de la volonté de des uns et des autres
de participer à ses entretiens parce que
là on voit bien que c'est en train de de
se tendre à nouveau je sais pas si notre
équipe sur place peut prendre le relais
pour nous expliquer de quoi elle
retourne là aux abords de la place de la
Nation et on a aussi ces images de
pompiers qui se mettent en travers de la
route
sans doute voilà en signe d'action
est-ce que ce sont des manifestants ou
des pompiers en intervention une canne
et ces caneton on trouvait le guide
idéal pour traverser Paris
dans une vidéo publiée sur Tik Tok et vu
plus de 10 millions de fois en quelques
jours une femme accompagne des canards
dans une rue du sixième arrondissement
pour les protéger des voitures chute
spectaculaire sur le Tour de Bretagne
survenu hier lors de la 6e étape entre
Chateaubriand et Plancoët la chaussée
couverte de gouttes après si tout fait
le peloton dans une chute presque
collective plusieurs coureurs ont été
contraints à l'abandon